so again Jory's opposite actually the
show is all positive because all you've
got on the right hand side all as we
value show everything going to polish
and we can do anything now I wonder how
comfortable your sail you get is just
individual absolute value graph if I
just said the absolute others possible I
started to get an image in your mind you
you know what's going to do that nasty
thing right you know what's going to do
that balancing what is the plus one okay
I'm going to take advantages of the
lashing though for a long time back when
graphing parabolas
do you remember everyone knows what this
looks like everyone has a good idea of
what that shape is me midline okay now
what's going to be in that shape and
this shape the answer is what we call a
horizontal shift like so the whole thing
that's sort of a happy shake it has
moved to the left okay now look at me
because that plus one plot usually means
to write right but you can all easily
check it because if you say okay my self
is find the x intercept you can say Oh
negative one is the thing I put in there
to get any sit down it so instead of
having its vertical garden kind of [ __ ]
ain't going to be one you know T well
this does exactly the same thing like if
I just gave you
regular old absolute value of x you know
it's going to bounce right there at the
origin but that pops one meeting you're
going to come over one more unit so this
is what I'm going to get
okay so there's my first pot what about
X minus three we chopped the SP value
sighs about that
which way am i shifting now I'm going to
the right and I'm going freedom okay so
that's maybe one try and make sure your
scale is somewhat consistent I'm going
to go one two three and annoys your same
wraps
okay now these bluegrass neither of them
is actually what I'm supposed to ground
I'm supposed to graph what happens when
you add them together okay so to see
what's happening I want to go tiny
little needle water right firstly a
result something nice and simple which
is PC if you cover up an apple TV not
really but if you cover up your in a
higher graphic user draws
except for the parts to the right of X
equal three just cover up everything
except for that okay we want to add
these two graphs together well one has a
grating of one the other one also is
agreeing with one so we add them
together what reading do you expect to
get ready one screen one I think that
gives you grieve you too right look it's
kind of like this guys pulling up and if
it's also pulling off so if you pull up
together you're going to go to deeper
[ __ ] do you agree with that so here's
what could happen if you draw a line off
like this from a sequence tree you can
draw a little circle bit because you're
adding this to this right whatever that
happens to be well this is zero plus
something up happens to be four okay so
zero plus four is equal to four so I
know maybe there and then what happens
when you add these two guys together is
that the result will be steeper than the
both of them you see that so it's kind
of like look it's increasing its
increasing think about it like to you
and a friend pouring water into a box
all right so if you're pouring in
individually the rate goes up if your
friend is pour it in the regular thought
well if you boil at the same time it's
going to get fall off faster somebody
cooks so that's what that looks like you
can see it's getting fuller faster and
constant possible
okay so far so good now have a look over
gr do the same thing cover a photograph
at this time rather than to the right of
the screen cover it up to the left of
negative one which is me let's go over
here
you didn't save Ben Ben in Reverse this
is not YouTube putting water into your
bath and it's getting fuller and fuller
and fuller this is you to try to get
water out of the ship like oh no we're
thinking get your buckets out one of
your friends is getting one out and your
other you are also getting water out so
together water is coming out Fox bar but
if you're doing individually is that
okay
so again you can draw a line it's going
so there and if you put them together
greenie negative one and now the greater
their debut one and combined is the
great in inspiration right now the
reason I did it in this funny order is
now you can see what's happening as
lesson of the right I wonder if you can
work out what's happening between on the
right hand side I've set your brush
putting water into the vine yeah you're
combining at it over here are your boys
pulling water out you coming down
tipping over edge what is happening in
between yeah there is a straight line I
should point out I already have two
straight lines
what kind of strip line are you
referring to yeah okay now the question
is one horizontal well if this part of
the grass is like both of you quarter
water is and this part of grass is both
of you get more around what's happening
in the middle well I think you are
pouring what it is and your friends
because the jerk press is pulling water
out at exactly the same time and exactly
the same right because one of you has
gradient one and the other has radius
negative one do you see that so what
happened
the result is used exactly cancel out
with each other how much is the water
level change and the answer it is not
it's just staying level because you guys
are fighting okay so therefore this
combined graph is is it you're not
that's the whole shape of the graph by
the way what is that flat line
it's going to default and you can test
that out if you want you can do the
algebra in between here that's also my
level which pressures are we adding up
the middle which of the branches are
being funded is this this is y equals x
minus 3 and this is 1/3 minus 1/2
but in this part in here for 0 1 3 the
bracelet interested in are this one here
you see oh that's 3 minus X and this one
here which is X plus 1 y equals x plus 1
plus 3 minus X so here was going to
happen the other one happen clouds in
third axis they cancel each other out
because remember what do you port the
port of water in and the other one is
taking for around crazy so they go on
and then what happens to these guys they
just write just like you predicted